this girl I met on the airplane she was
flying and she couldn't see outside at
the sky and the sunset that was going on
but she felt the heat of it so she would
just ask me what it looked like so I
described as her so I remember because I
appreciate sight because of her one time
I was working a part-time as an uber
driver and I picked up this man he was
from Vietnam somehow it's been kind of a
long time but I remember him telling me
how many people died Vietnamese died in
the Vietnam War and how he because of
what had happened he had to go to
training and like right when he was done
with training was like this second they
stopped the war so he didn't have to go
and the whole time was hit this story he
was telling me on the way to hit where I
was taking him to his destination and he
said you know sometimes people are very
lucky I was a very lucky man and he said
sometimes not so lucky and I was
dropping him off at the Cancer Center
and I don't know why but it just touched
me so much that he shared that with me
and it's always stuck with me and he was
a very lovely man and I'll always
remember him to this day I just wish
that I had stayed with him because I
don't think anyone was there with him
before his cancer treatment that's what
I wish to this day I was in Pompeii and
this older Italian couple was there just
as some tourists looking at the pompeii
ruins and they saw that we were
Americans and they came up to me just
out of the blue and they said are you
American and I said yes and they're like
threw their arms around me and said
thank your grandparents you saved our
lives
who always loved Americans Rory did for
us after World War two and as a young
American and I never really realized the
hug from those old people I didn't even
know just because we were Americans I
remember I saw this this homeless man
and his two daughters in this alcove in
Chicago one night I'll just always
remember it wishing I could do something
more wishing I would have done something
I was working in a grocery store just
like heading somewhere to go put
something away this guy goes you don't
look like you belong here you look like
you should be in a larger city doing
something important so are you in a big
city now yeah what are you doing I'm a
jewelry designer so we do say that he
was right and that okay came to you yeah
and I never thought about that and
you'll probably be the third stranger I
remember like ten years later so it was
in Phuket Islands silence so I met this
girl who came from South Africa and I
don't know I must have been like 14 and
so we met at the swimming pool and we
play like ping pong and everything and
at that time I didn't speak a word of
English or like with the Singaporean
accents because I lived there and she
kept on helping me
having a better accent and particularly
particularly for three the thing with
the tongue that we in French in French
we don't do and so I remember that she
kept on telling me say three three three
have this in mind and while we were
taking the boat you have the de motor of
the boat which makes a lot of sounds and
I was training myself because I knew
that no one around could hear me and I
was like just like three three three I
remember this girl who was pretty as
well and really nice and thanks to her I
learned the thing with the tongue to
speak English that's the story I was
doing Peace Corps in Guatemala and for
some reason I was really late in getting
to my bus to take me to my little
village and so I knew I was not supposed
to be walking at night by myself but I
didn't have any other choice so I was by
myself walking to the bus station which
is kind of a little Shady
and this man comes up to me and he says
stay with me right now you need to walk
take a right take a right and I was like
what's going on and he's like you're
you're in danger right now and so he
kept walking and got out of there and
there was I guess I allegedly a group of
guys or a gang that was there that were
that were watching me come in and so I
went to his house he took me there and
he fed me dinner with his kids and ended
up driving me up
my house and so I was a pretty amazing
experience so what made you trust him um
I don't know there was something about
his motive that felt like it was
altruistic that he really cared had no
idea it was just instinctual and really
fast but it actually wasn't very long
ago in fact it was on Friday I went ice
skating on my own and as I was leaving
the ice-skating rink I heard a little
voice say hola and I looked down and it
was a little Down syndrome girl and like
full figure skating outfit with her
little figure skating skates on and she
was waving at me and it was she was
super super cute so what does that stand
out to you do think I have a Down
syndrome uncle who is one of my favorite
people in the world
yeah so when when I saw her just might
be really happy so I was at a grocery
store at home and I was looking at
coffee creamer and I showmen came up to
me and told me that my eyes looked
beautiful and that I was really pretty
and he made me feel really good about
myself and so yeah why do you think that
meant so much to you because I have very
low self-esteem and I'm very
[Music]
self-conscious about everything about me
and so he just made me feel really good
about myself and the fact that it was
from a stranger and not prompted from
any friends or family or anything I
think that's kind of what really made it
feel so special and like okay it was
really genuine and it's not
he wasn't just telling me because it's
something I wanted to hear I got in a
car accident and I spun around like six
times and I end up hitting trees and
then he just added up everybody who
passed by me he was the one who came
getting me out of the trees he drugged
me out he was like hey are you all right
I was like yeah what happened he was
like well you just crashes with trees
and then he like he told me it was a
retired EMT so he helped me out a lot
but everybody that passed by ain't
nobody really like stopped to help me
out and then this random guy see me I'm
seeing me crashing inside a row he
stopped to help me out
I was a good guy Ricardo una and Sienna
Colombia movio and allowed to booze and
it was in she told me something like -
it is Pelle Rojo and los pelos belarusan
person asked a dancer de MFA is co l
Brussels if espera la - Earth Day it's a
point you're like what I was a cashier
at Home Depot and I'm non-binary I'm
trans feminine I have a really
complicated relationship with gender
that is a big source of I guess I could
even say emotional torment for me and
trans grow payments in my line who fully
embodied everything that I wanted to be
and struck a nerve with me
and as our transaction continued and I
rang her up and her card kept declining
and declining and declining it was just
like look like if I can help this person
I will
I hate that cost I just inserted my card
so it was just like here you go
I thought that was gonna be it we left
went about our day she comes back
completely surprised with $20 bill in
hand hands it to me gives me a giant hug
and tells me that she's really grateful
for what I did for and that I can be
like hers to some day and that it'll get
better and I never really forgot about
that if you're out there and if you see
this thank you it still means a lot
can you try to describe to us what
she said that to you I felt less alone I
felt like I wasn't a freak or that I
wasn't weird or outlandish for feeling
that way and it made me feel like other
people experience the same thing and
even though I know other people's spirit
experience that I'm not the only
freaking non-binary kid in the world
that still feels like it sometimes
and knowing out that there are people
out there with the same kindness in
their hearts that you like to keep in
yours this is a really comforting
feeling one stranger that stood out to
me was actually this couple they were
probably in their late 50s I remember
walking to school every morning almost
mornings and even on mornings where I
would walk to school I would drive by
because they would always walk past me
and they would just be walking next to
each other whether it was raining the
weather was even if it was absolutely
excuse my language they would always be
with each other always talking every
morning it was when I was in high school
so three four years ago and I still
wonder like if they're still walking
down that path they're still talking
thirty days ago it's an airplane this
man offered me a hundred dollars to
switch seats of him I didn't so
the most memorable must reason
why do you think it's livable because no
one ever offers me money do things but
not that I want that but like I don't
want like strings attached I'll be weird
like I feel like I'd be compelled to
like have a conversation with him I just
didn't have and so yeah I was twenty I
woke up somebody came out from under my
bed with a knife and a bandana and told
me they were gonna kill me and the only
thing I knew to do was to say Hail Marys
and he kept getting mad at me saying
what are you saying what are you saying
and I just kept saying hail Mary full of
grace and the next thing I know I come
up out of that bed with my fist and he's
against the wall and running out of my
home so to this day I'm glad I didn't do
it to you today when somebody awakens me
watch out oh never caught we moved and I
haven't had a negative stranger incident
since old one me too but what I was
really left with was the power of prayer
that's the end story that
what I remember it was a junior year of
high school I was in Boston in the Logan
Airport and I was killing a bunch of
time with my parents so I decided to
walk around there was this really really
long hallway with a bunch of moving
walkways and there was this lady with
her son with like seven suitcases like
running from one side to the other and I
wasn't doing anything so I was like
running along the moving walkway and I
asked her if she needed any help and she
didn't speak English very well but I was
like carrying her bags and then I just
tried to like make conversation and she
was saying that her her family
oh sorry her mom had like just passed
away so she was going to visit so I
thought kind of like resonated with me
because you really never know what
everyone's going through until you like
start the started the conversation so I
actually ran my college essay about that
and I'm in college now so it worked out
right it's kind of crazy because there's
this very specific emotion where you
could be surrounded by his first day in
college you're surrounded by so many
people on the same stage of life with
you but it's so easy to feel lonely you
definitely feel so some sort of hope
when you realize that everyone has so
many different stories if you don't get
to hear it we start the first
conversation so I love talking to
strangers this is what we're doing now
right yeah it's hard to take the first
step to start a conversation but I think
it's really important to do it in the
first place
yeah
hey guys thanks for watching another
episode if you haven't subscribed to my
channel yet and you want to subscribe to
my channel please make sure to hit the
subscribe button and a little ball next
to it so you'll get notified every time
I put up a new episode I think that's
pretty much it thank you guys again and
I'll see you next week
[Music]
you